[Music]
in camera Karma news Oh submitted by
chocolate nuts not one of our sponsors
chocolate last night no a man turns
himself in after this his plot to take
upskirt photos of women failed can I
guess that the city Japanese I think I'm
gonna go with her on that one do ya
I won't with just a white trash guy oh
that's a good one so based off of his
name and where he's from I would go with
white trash guy oh do we have photos of
his work no okay that's all Platt skirts
Japanese oh we don't like plaid skirts
Platt skirts and school shoes everybody
likes white pad skirts my last year hey
everybody
Pat skirts a coup yeah so this dude is
from Wisconsin he's 32 years old his
name is Hitoshi mushy my phone yeah the
name that I thought was the Chief of
Police I don't have his name okay so
David's gonna be like cooter bring these
strikes again good ol Heimlich over here
it's a Japanese exchange student in
Wisconsin that's the best name here so
what did he do all of us that and he
felt guilty and he decided you know what
this is wrong imma turn myself in he had
to have seen that he was gonna get
busted so what happened here was that he
apparently bought a shoe camera that's
[ __ ] shoot cameras exist it's on the
like a tip of your toe yeah so
apparently the cameras battery exploded
during a trial run oh my gosh
you can't even use it on anyone yet it
was just at home he was just testing it
out well he hurt his foot and then he
went to church and he kind of confessed
to his mentor who seems to be a priest
that he's been doing this for a long
time he's knocked on him with the
prison's mentor like as in he's the one
that taught him the way
it's a Catholic Church like this is his
mentor I just reported that when the
explosion happened he got treatment for
minor burns then disclosed what happened
to his mentor a clergyman oh there you
go it could be any one of those babe
yeah father I didn't do it the right way
you told me to father I have let you
down what did you charge the battery son
yeah I did I overcharged everyone was
getting the same thing I got what
everyone else got father I spoke to the
father that that's when he went to the
police station to turn himself in
he went to report a sex offense on
himself yeah yeah I can't be mad at that
but he didn't film anything he's
innocent
exactly this is a pre-crime why are you
so mad because it's like that Minority
Report [ __ ] dude on himself
that's like me wanting to kill somebody
and I go in the [ __ ] station I go I
murder someone who well not yet but I
wanted to they can't prosecute you for a
pre-crime right maybe so they they
didn't charge him with anything he
didn't do anything illegal
yeah but because he didn't take any
photos so he have to go and do it
he's like so wait so for me to get in
trouble I got to do it okay fine so he
goes and he takes the pictures and he
comes back look I did it that's [ __ ]
up what if a shoot camera is not even
like low-key it's like viewfinders on
the back of the tongue that would be the
hey what if it's like a DSLR dude yeah
with the mic and everything like he's a
dope shoes I had a chilling video I want
to do years ago that I couldn't do
because maker was like you legally
cannot do this but I wanted to dress up
as a [ __ ] toilet what it would set up
in a public restroom like it's so
obvious it's like that [ __ ] where it's
like it's a there's a little sign says
please feel free to use the toilet oh my
god
sitting there but inside the toilet is
like a clearly set up GoPro on a tripod
so I'm just sitting there like
[Laughter]
do you be inside a stall I would have
been in Australia that we would have
pre-arranged in the approve now I can
maybe do it cuz they don't have a legal
apparatus I'm a now what if someone need
to go really [ __ ] bad and they just
[ __ ] all over like it's a prank it's a
prank big [ __ ] like my face would have
been white like porcelain white like the
toilet but it's like obviously [ __ ]
toilets the toilet seats on your face ya
know so I like my face is like went into
the tank part right okay and then like
my so there's a toilet seat on your
thigh yeah right exactly it's what my
hands come down here like this [ __ ] your
hands are the feet my hands are like
well they're part of that they're
blended with the seat but they're not
like it's like there's a seat real seat
and then my hands playing with this here
didn't they prove the video of you it
were yours a car seat yeah well that was
for a movie though Palestine thank you
but yeah so if you would have taken any
photos this dude and Wisconsin it is
outlawed why doesn't he just watch porn
it does carry a maximum sentence of
three and a half years in prison and a
fine of $10,000 damn is that the
sentence in the United States for
upskirt specifically I remember I saw
some obscure videos when I was about 19
or 20 thought it was hot but it got over
real quick that [ __ ] was like pogs
part of the hot back then though it was
hot it was hot and then it left and then
I started thinking these girls probably
allow it oh you mean to say it was faked
yeah I think I see why it turns people
on because even if you have a girlfriend
or whatever it's like the act of doing
some ninja ass pervert [ __ ] none of that
[ __ ] would fly it nowadays at all I
don't think it's right at all I'm just
saying like I can see why people can get
into that kind of stuff that's like what
happened to Erin Andrews man like
remember that she's like a sports
announcer girl who's like consider it
like very hot chick alright somebody got
a hotel room next to her hotel room
drilled a [ __ ] hole in the wall like
film her changing like guys do crazy she
won a lawsuit against the guys it's
[ __ ] up you know I mean cuz I mean
like she was completely traumatized oh
yeah [ __ ] yeah
I'm doing her thing that's I'm saying
that's but crazy yeah that's like it
follow sleeping and then I woke up and
does like ten dudes jacking off watching
me oh that's traumatizing for you you
know what I probably be doing I'll
probably go solving with Joe you
wouldn't even try to fight them you know
what I'm picturing what like player
football player Samoan dude with raging
boners yeah ten-foot dicks dude I'm just
like thank God they don't they're not
raping me right now that's sometimes
it's like you you feel like sometimes
you go back to sleep things will just go
away but they're just still there during
yeah [ __ ] alright just take the come
on care I do all those mmm
you wake up in psycho there god it's
like I was on the dream and then you
feel your sheets you get up and it's
like you're [ __ ] opening a crypt if
[Laughter]
you're if you wake up then it just I
don't know man I'm finished
hurry up and finish yeah 10 guys with
the jizz
yeah I don't know what to do I hope they
just I mean it's not gonna be that
[ __ ] crazy it's not like you you're
not gonna be able to breathe you know
yeah I mean it's fiscally home it's
[ __ ] laundromat in there it's
not like just come and gives life have
some respect itself it's true it's true
yes it's just got it pretty much does
when you put in the right place as a
baby comes up yeah what she's saying
she's providing the egg this is why I'm
gonna tell Nicky next time I'll be like
it's just calm it is just calm so if I
can relax a little bit about it yeah
Nicky it's just calm see Mickey has the
same texture egg yolk no it does it like
a podcast name it's just--come the
podcast oh I'm dead yeah
yeah I got one and and in the works is
it gonna be an hour of freestyle rapping
what conversations in freestyle form no
I'm not like freestyle rap is like a
nightmare to be right now I don't know
is there anybody who doesn't have yeah
well we technically do well personally
you don't discount all the people who
don't have a podcast make a podcast
together that's true get it over yeah
cuz everyone's gonna do you guys have a
podcast we do camera shoot shoot camera
perverts
no we were on the right track sourdough
it off the record that camera is pretty
much the same and that's all it could
really be used for up skirts like what
else is the suit cat why does this shoe
cam exist
the most intense shot of a soccer ball
okay I get this POV of getting like
kicking a soccer ball you can have that
no it's like if you want to vlog kicking
somebody that's like oh my god i watch
these these like hacks like life hacks
things on Instagram and one of them was
like if you don't have a selfie stick
just put on a sandals that fit perfectly
by the way like that was like you
planned it Oh show him your feet they're
TIFF get him up there nice and big there
you go now wiggle those toes for us tip
i saw one girl all the fans at home she
took this selfie right so she's in her
bathroom and it's those big mirrors she
took a selfie like this trying to see
her ass so all [ __ ] I got caught she was
like this and she sticks to [ __ ]
phone dinner she held it and then she
like took at old pictures Wow but you
see with phone and her yeah
[Music]